the announcement that US attorney john
Durham's investigation is now a criminal
probe has made a lot of folks nervous in
this town and they're all the same Intel
and media collaborators who spread the
phony collusion narrative from the start
minutes after seeing the news former
Obama Director of National Intelligence
James clapper appeared on television and
was it just me or did he seem to
struggle to get out the right words well
I should uh I'm very curious since
presumably I guess I'm one of those
under investigation
I found the timing interesting given the
increasing heat around the impeachment
inquiry do you have any idea even what
they might think may rise to the level
of a criminal offense no I don't that's
obviously an item of great interest to
me past that depends all right for his
part former deputy director of the FBI
Andrew McCabe on CNN sought to shift the
focus of the convo there appears to be
within the administration well from the
president and now possibly with the
Attorney General as well an underlying
lack of trust and if those
decision-makers are not convinced as it
suggests that they are not taking the
Russian threat to the 2020 elections as
seriously as they show we made the
obvious and rational decision to
investigate well remember what cave is
the guy who himself is under criminal
investigation and is suing the DOJ in
desperation perhaps in the quebra cNN's
Jim judo was its kudo himself a former
Obama national security official might
have thought about disclosing that in
the conversation and finally did MSNBC
hire Alex Jones this bizarro world
treasure hunt for dirt on our own
intelligence services to try to set up
Russia's interference in our election as
a false flag operation according to this
conspiracy theory Russia didn't do that
Russia didn't intervene what actually
happened is that it was the Obama
raishin that was setting this all up as
a frame job
I actually felt bad for the folks over
the other networks now last night I mean
it came late the news came late they
didn't have time to fully process it
marinate in it some tinfoil hats might
have been on a little too tight
well these same people spent two years
of course promoting the Russia hoax and
they hyped every detail of the Muller
probe while claiming it wasn't
politically motivated and instead of
embracing an investigation by a highly
respected attorney well they're just
lashing out they're trying to discredit
dirham of all people who's as bipartisan
accolades for him but not any longer
well and he has to finish his work